this was a day decades in the making for
Richard Branson a day that would end
with him officially designated an
astronaut
[Applause]
slung beneath a plane named in honor of
his mother Eve they lifted off from the
runway in the New Mexico Heat
and at 46 000 feet spaceship Unity was
released three two one
ignition
good rocket motor burn
there's Mach One rocketing up to the
edge of space we are 25 seconds into the
burn now approaching Mach 2.
50 miles up the engine cut and for a few
minutes they experienced the
weightlessness of zero gravity the
pilots are now unlocking the feather and
as soon as they do that it's going to
initiate a backflip for spaceship Unity
this is normal we want those windows
pointed down towards the Earth to
maximize that incredible View
quite a moment for the first billionaire
in space
[Music]
a beautiful Spaceport
congratulations to everybody for for
creating such a beautiful beautiful
place
those few minutes have cost an awful lot
but the Journey Back Down to Earth was a
smooth one Unity touching down on the
runway the whole thing it lasted barely
an hour
lots of achievement clear for the world
to see did I ever doubt it would happen
I I'm sure if I'm honest with myself
there were moments where uh you know
tough moments but we were you know this
wonderful group of Engineers have stuck
with it
um and uh and I just could not be
happier that we we finally achieved this
dream
he says for his grandchildren's
generation this turns the dream of space
travel into a reality and that this is
the dawn of a new space age
Milam Sky News New Mexico
[Music]